the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
so let's get started with the second
lecture for today so I guess one thing
multi Cosby is clearly shatter this nice
view of freighting single programs and
hardware is going to take care of giving
you performance so how do I just kind of
a completely gay gave that up but so
what we are doing in this class is we
will try and do it by yourself get all
the responsibilities back to the program
so the ad and you realize as you go it's
much harder job I mean this is not
simple programming and you need to have
you don't have MIT class students on
every company to do this so so we need
to have truck at a middle ground and so
so once some of the stuff we have been
doing SP sir it's fine to figure out
other images now can he actually take
some of that load away from the user
into things like languages and compilers
so we will talk about some of those pics
so right now be a kind of switching from
directly queenly what's necessary to do
the cell project into girl nisbet breath
so this lecture and then we will sit
back a little bit into debugging and
force Martin that will be directly
helpful and the next week we'll have
bunch of guest lectures who kind of give
you bread in there so she will
understand not just sell programming but
in parallel programming and parallel
processing what the world is like beyond
that so so baby a good bit of a stream
okay very good so my name is Bill T so
I'm a graduate student working with
someone and Roderick and others here and
i'll talk about the stream at language
so why do we need a new programming
language well we think that languages
haven't kept up with the architectures
so one way to look at this is that if
you look back at previous languages look
at sea with a von Neumann machine ah now
I grew up in rural Pennsylvania and not
too far from Amish country and so to me
these go together just like a horse and
buggy okay they're perfectly made for
each other they basically go at the same
rate everything is fine but the problem
is in comes the modern architecture okay
this is an f-16 you have a lot more that
you can do with
with a horse and buggy so how do you
program these new architectures well
architecture makers these days are
basically faced with a really hard
choice on the one hand you could get a
really cool architecture and develop can
to an ad hoc programming technique where
you're really just leaving it to the
programmer to do something complicated
to get performance and unfortunately I
think that's the the route to date I
mean fortunately for the industry but
unfortunately for you I think that's the
route they took with cell which means
all of you are going to become basically
fighter pilots you have to learn how to
fly the plane you have to become an
expert you're going to become the best
people at programming these
architectures and unfortunately the only
other option is to really bend over
backwards to support the previous era of
languages like C and C++ and you can see
what's coming here it's just hard to get
off the runway so ok you don't want the
situation just out of consideration for
whoever's in the buggy hopefully you'll
never take off so looking from a more
academic perspective why do we need a
new language right now so if you look
back over the past 30 years I know
you've seen this graph before we were
dealing with just one core in the
machine for all this time and now we
have this plethora of multicores coming
across the board so how did we program
these old machines well we had languages
like C and Fortran that really had a lot
of nice properties across these
architectures so it was portable
high-performance composable you could
have really good software development
malleable maintainable all the nice
things you'd like to see from a software
engineering perspective and really if
you wrote a program back in nineteen
seventy you could keep it in C and have
it continue to leverage all the new
properties of machines over the past
thirty years they're just run fine out
of the box and looking forward that's
not going to be true so for example we
could say that C was a common machine
language that's what we say for the past
30 years was common across all the
machines but now looking forward that's
not going to be true anymore because you
have to program every core separately so
what's the common machine language for
multi course we really think you need
something where you can write a program
once today and have it scale for the
next 30 years without having to modify
the program so what kind of language do
you need to get that kind of performance
well let's look a little deeper into
this notion of a common machine language
so why did it work so well for the past
30 years well on you know processors odd
things like seein Fortran really
encapsulated the common properties so
things like a single flow of control in
the machine a single memory image are
both properties of the language but they
also hid certain properties from the
programmer so they hid the things that
were different between one machine and
another so for example the register file
the ISA the functional units and so on
these things could change from one
architecture to another and you didn't
have to change your program because
those aspects weren't in the programming
language so that's why these languages
were succeeding and what do we need to
succeed in the multi-core era from a
language perspective well you need to
encapsulate the common properties again
and this time it's multiple flows of
control that you have for all the
different cores in multiple local
memories there's no more monolithic
memory anymore that everyone can read
and write to also you need to hide some
of the differences between the machines
so some coors have different
capabilities on cell there's a
heterogeneous system between the SPS and
the PPE different communication models
on different architectures different
synchronization models so whatever
common machine language we come up with
will have to keep these things hidden
from the programmer now a lot of
different researchers are taking
different tax for how you want to invent
the next common machine language and the
thrust that we're really excited about
is this notion of streaming so what is
this dream program well if you look at a
lot of the high performance saw systems
today including PowerPoint which is
running this awesome animation you can
basically see that they're there based
around some stream of data so audio
video like HGTV video editing graphics
stuff I think actually a lot of the
projects in this class that I look sad
which fit into the the streaming mold
things like the software radio ray
tracing I probably remember the mall
except when I looked at them they all
looked like they had a streaming
component somewhere in there so what's
special about a stream program compared
to just a normal program well they have
a lot of attractive properties if you
look at their structure you can usually
see that the the computation pattern
remains relatively constant
ask the lifetime of the program so they
have some well-defined units that are
communicating with each other and they
continue that pattern of communication
throughout and this really exposes a lot
of opportunities for the compiler to do
some optimization that it couldn't do on
just an arbitrary general-purpose
program and as you saw before we have
basically all the types of parallelism
are really exposed in a stream program
there's the pipeline parallelism between
different producers and consumers
there's the task parallelism basically
going from left to right and also data
parallelism which means that a single
one of these stages can sometimes be
split to apply some multiple elements in
the data stream so when you're thinking
about stream programming there's a lot
of different ways you can actually
represent the program so whenever you
have a programming model you have to
answer these kinds of questions for
example do the senders and the receivers
block when they try to communicate how
much buffering is allowed as the
complication deterministic what kind of
model do you have in there can you avoid
deadlock questions like these and we
could spend the whole lecture answering
these questions putting them in
different categories but what I want to
do just to give you a feel is touch on
kind of three of the major models that
you might see come up in different kinds
of programming models and I'll just
touch on Kahn process networks
synchronous dataflow and communicating
sequential processes or CSP so just one
slide on these models so let's compare
them a little bit first is the con
process networks so this is kind of the
simplest model it's very intuitive you
just have different processes that are
communicating over 50 s and the FIFO
size is conceptually unbounded so is the
first approximation is kind of like a
UNIX pipe these processes can just read
from the inputs and they can push on to
their outputs without blocking but if
they try to read from an input they do
block until an input is available and
the interesting thing is that the
communication pattern can actually be
dependent on the data so for example I
could pop an index off of one channel
and then use that index to determine
which other channel I'll read from on
the next time step but at the same time
it is deterministic so for a given Syria
the input values on the streams I'll
always have the same communication
pattern that I'm trying from the other
inputs so it's a deterministic model
that's a nice property I let's see what
else to say here there's actually a few
recent ventures that are using Khan
process networks so there's of
commercial interest for example am brick
is a startup that I think will be based
on a con process network for the
programming model looking at another
model called synchronous dataflow this
is actually what we used in the streamit
system and compared to contrast this
networks it's kind of a subset is a
little bit more restrictive so if you
look at the space of all possible
program behaviors con process networks
are a pretty big piece of the space and
then synchronous dataflow is kind of a
subset of that space where you know more
about the communications pattern at
compile time so for example in
synchronous dataflow the programmer
actually declares how many items it will
consume from each of its input channels
on a given execution step so there's no
more data dependence regarding the
communication pattern it'll always input
some items from some of the channels and
produce some number of items to other
channels and this is a really nice
property because it lets the compiler do
the scheduling for you so the compiler
can see who's communicating to who in
exactly what pattern and then it can
statically in or leave the filters to
guarantee that everyone has enough data
to complete their computation so there's
a lot of interesting optimizations you
can do here that's why it's very
attractive for stream it and you can
statically guarantee freedom from
deadlock which is the nice property to
have the last one I want to touch on is
communicating sequential processes or
CSP and in the space the program
behaviors it's kind of an overlapping
set from con process networks and adds a
few new semantic behaviors so the
buffering model is basically rendezvous
communication now so there's no
buffering in the system basically
anytime you send a value to another
process you have to block and wait until
that process will actually receive that
value from you so everyone is Ron
debuting at every communication step so
in addition to that they have some
sophisticated synchronization
primitives so you can for example
discuss alternative behaviors that you
have you can do either one thing or
another which will introduce them non
determinism in the model it which which
could be a good or a bad thing depending
on the program you're trying to express
and pretty much the the most well-known
encapsulation of CSP is this awesome
programming language I invented quite a
while ago and some people are still
using that today any questions on the
models computations okay so now let me
get into what stream it is so stream it
is it's a great language it's a high
level architecture independent language
Oh question in the back CSD model yeah
I'm trying to understand exactly what
that means or how he's different is it
is it just basically it is basically
what it's saying is you have a bunch of
processes and making send messages to
each other so all of these models have
that property and see but it seemed it
seemed like from your explanation of CSP
right that that's sort of that was just
sort of the essence of GSP ah right so
CH is it so CSP is usually associated
with rendezvous communication that's the
bestest set of programs that fit inside
con process networks is any
communicating model where you basically
have no buffering between the processes
now the piece that sits outside is
usually lumped with CSP or especially
with awesome they have a set of
primitives that are richer in terms of
synchronization so for example you can
have guards on your communication don't
execute this this consumption from this
channel until I see a certain value so
there's some richer more rich semantics
there and so that's the things that are
usually outside outside the the other
models so that make sense other
questions
okay so stream it okay so stream it is
architecture independent it's basically
a really nice I submitted syntactic
model for interfacing with these lower
level models of computation for
streaming and really we have two goals
in the streamit project and the first is
the from the programmers side so we want
to improve the programmers life when
you're writing a parallel program we
want to make it easier for you to write
a parallel program then you would have
to do and see or language like Java or
any other language that you know and at
the same time we want scalable and
portable performance across the multi
course so an interesting thing these
days is you'll find is it's often very
hard to tempt a programmer to switch to
your favorite language based solely on
performance or at least this has been
the story in the past it may change
looking forward because it's a lot
harder to get performance these days but
usually you have to offer them some
other carrot to get them on board and
you know the carrot here is that it's
really nice to program in its fund
program in it's beautiful it's a lot
easier to program and stream it then it
would be in something like C or Java for
a certain class of programs so that's
how we get them on board and then we
also provide the performance we're
mostly based on the synchronous dataflow
model and that we went when there are
static communication patterns we
leverage that from the compiler side
they'll also tell you about some dynamic
extensions that we have that's a much
richer model of communication so what
have we been doing in the streamit
project we have kind of a dual thrust
within our group building on this
language so the first thrust is from the
programmability side looking at
applications and programmability what
can we fit into the streaming model and
we're also really pushing the
optimizations so what can you do from
both a domain-specific optimization
standpoint that's kind of emulating a
DSP engineer a signal processing expert
in the design flow and also architecture
specific optimizations so we've been
compiling for a lot of parallel machines
and we're hoping we could have a full
system for you guys this IP so you could
write it and stream it and hit the
button and it would work the whole way
down to sell unfortunately we're not
quite there yet but we do have a pretty
robust
compiler infrastructure and you can
download this off the web and play with
it if you want to one of our backends
that we've released so far actually does
go to to a cluster of workstations so
it's kind of an MPI like version of see
it uses a P threads for the parallelism
model and I mean depending on what kind
of a hacker you are you actually might
be able to lower that down on to sell so
some of the stuff you might be able to
use if you're if you're I have some
initiative in there and of course would
be willing to work with you on this as
well so we have a lot of optimizations
in the tool flow and actually saman will
spend another lecture focusing on the
stream at compiler and how we get a
performance out of this model okay so
let's just jump right in and do the
analog of hello world in stream it I'm
going to kind of walk you through the
language and show you the interesting
pieces from an intellectual standpoint
what's interesting about a streaming
model that you can take away so instead
of hello world we have a counter since
we're dealing with stream programs here
you're not usually doing text processing
so how do you write a counter well there
are two pieces to the program the first
is kind of the interconnect between the
different components that's what we have
up here we're saying the program is the
pipeline with two stages that has a
source and it has a printer and then we
can write the source than the printer as
filters we call those basic building
blocks filters and stream it so the
source will just have a variable X that
it initializes 20 and then we have a
work function which is automatically
called by our runtime system every time
through the steady state so this work
function will push one item on to the
output channel and it will increment the
value afterwards whereas the int printer
at the bottom here will input one value
and its work function here just pops
that value off the input tape and prints
it to the output now how do we run this
thing well there's no main function here
like you see in hello world was there a
comment sorry
who means of push and means of 12 money
sexual another 12 people yeah yeah so
the first push here is is just declaring
that this work function will push one
items the output tape so this is the
synchronous dataflow aspect we're
associating an output rate with this
work function so it's a declaration here
whereas this push is just actually
executing the push onto the output so
how do we run this thing will we compile
it with the stream and compiler store
see into a binary and then when we run
we run for a given number of iterations
so you don't just call it once our model
is that this is the continuous stream of
data going through the program and so
when you run it you run it for some
number of iterations or basically input
or output items is what you're running
it for so if you run this for four
iterations it would print the value zero
through three so we can we can leverage
this steady flow of data yeah I'm here
one two three four pushing xbox I think
the plus + is executed after the push so
it starts at zero so I think a post
fistic postfix expression execute after
the actual expression yeah yeah other
questions okay so let's step up a level
and look at what we have in stream it so
the first question is how do you
represent this connectivity between
different building blocks how do you
represent streams and if you look at
traditional programming models kind of
the conventional wisdom is that a stream
program is a graph you have different
nodes that are communicating to each
other and graphs are actually kind of
hard to analyze their hard to represent
their a little bit confusing so the
approach we decided to take in stream it
is one of a structured computation graph
so instead of having arbitrary
interconnections between stages we have
a hierarchical description in which
every individual stage has a single
input in a single output and then you
can compose these together into
higher-level stages of course there are
some stages that do split and join with
multiple inputs we'll get to that so the
analog here is kind of analogous to a
structured control flow
in your favorite imperative programming
language of course there was a day when
everyone used go-to statements instead
of having structured control fuh we got
a fan of go-to statements in the
audience okay I'll get to you later so
but the problem was it's really hard to
understand a program that's jumping all
over the place because there's no local
reasoning you can have you know you're
jumping to this location you're coming
back a different way it's hard to reason
about program components so when people
went to structured control flow but just
if else I for loop yeah for loop
statements and those are the two basic
constructs you can basically express all
kinds of computation in those simple
primitives and things got a lot simpler
and you know people objected at one
point even you know what about a finite
state machine don't you need go-to
statements for a finite state machine
going from one state to another and now
everyone writes in fsm with a really
simple idiom usually have a while loop
around a case statement right you have a
dispatch loop so now whenever you see
that pattern you can recognize oh
there's the finite state machine it's
not just a set of go tues it's a finite
state machine so we think there are
similar idioms in the streaming domain
and that's kind of the direction we're
pushing from a design standpoint so what
are our structures that we have well
here are structured streams at the base
we have a filter that's just the
programmable unit like I showed you we
have a pipeline which just connects one
stream to another in a sequence so this
gives you pipeline parallelism there's a
split join where you have explicit
parallelism in the stream so I'll talk
about what these splitters and joiners
can do is basically a predefined pattern
of scattering data to some child's
dreams and then gathering that data back
into a single stream so the whole
construct still remains single input in
single output likewise the feedback loop
is just a simple way to put a ax a loop
and you're in your stream and of course
these are hierarchical so all of these
green boxes can be any of the three
constructs so that's how you can have
these hierarchical graphs and again
since everything is single input single
output you can really mix and match you
know choose your favorite components and
they'll always fit together you don't
need to stitch multiple connections so
let's dive inside one of these filters
now and I gave you a feel for how they
look before but here's a little more
detail
so how do we program the filter well a
filter just transforms one stream into
another stream and here's transforming a
stream of floating-point numbers into
another floating point number stream it
can take some parameters at the top
these are actually fixed at compile time
in our model which allows the compiler
to really specialized the filters code
depending on the context in which is
being used so for example here we're
inputting n in a frequency and then we
have two stages of execution at
initialization time this runs once at
the beginning of the whole program we
can calculate some weights for example
from the frequency and we can store
those weights as a local variable so you
can think of this kind of like a Java
class you can have some member variables
you can retain state from one execution
to the next the work function is the
closest thing to the main function this
is called repeatedly in the steady state
enter the i/o rates of the work function
this filter actually peaks at some data
items that means that it inspects more
items on the input channel then it
actually consumes on every iteration so
we'll look at n input items and we'll
push one new item on to the output and
pop one item from the input tape every
time we execute so here we have a
sliding window computation it means the
next time through will just slide this
window up by one and inspect the next n
items on the input tape and inside the
work function you can have pretty much
general purpose code right now we
disallow pointers and a few other things
to keep things simple but the idea is
this is general purpose imperative code
inside the work function now what's nice
about this representation of a filter is
well for one thing is this peak function
so what we really have is a nice
representation of the data pattern that
you're reading the data on the input
channel and if you look at this for
example in a language like C it's a lot
Messier so usually when you're doing
buffer management you have to do some
modulo operations you have to keep a
circular buffer of your live data and
increase you know a head or a tail
pointer and mod around the side with
some kind of modulo operation and for a
compiler this is a real nightmare
because modulo operations are kind of
the worst thing to analyze you can't see
what is actually trying to read and if
you want to map this buffer to a network
or to a combined communication
with some other actor or filter in the
graph is pretty much impossible so here
is we're exposing that all to the
compiler and you'll see how that can
make a difference and also it's just a
lot easier to program I mean I don't
like looking at this code so I'm going
to go to the next slide okay so how do
we piece things together let's just
build some higher-level components so
here's a pipeline of two components and
we already saw a pipeline you can just
add one component after another and add
just basically has the effect of making
a queue and just queuing up all of the
components that you added and connecting
them one after another so here we have a
band pass filter by connecting a low
pass filter and feeding us output into a
high pass filter end up with a band pass
filter okay what about a split join how
do we make those I so split join has an
ad statement as well and here we're
adding components in a loop so what this
means is now when we say add we're
actually adding from left to right so
instead of going top to down we're
adding from left to right across the
split drawing and we can actually do
that in a loop so here we're imprinting
a parameter n and depending on that
value will add n band pass filters to
the split join so this is kind of cool
right because you can input a parameter
and that parameter actually affects the
structure of your graph so this is this
graph is unrolled at compile time by our
compiler constructing a big sequence of
computations and it can resolve the
structure and communication pattern in
that graph and then map it to the
underlying substrate when we compile me
also to notice here at the splitter and
the joiner so I have a predefined set of
splitters and joiners I'll go into more
detail later but here we're just
duplicating the data to every one of
these parallel components and then doing
a round-robin join pattern where we
bring them back together I into a single
output stream and if you want to do an
equalizer you basically need an adder at
the bottom to add the different
components together and another thing
you can notice here is that we have some
inlining going on so we actually
embedded the split drawing inside a
higher level pipeline so what this does
is it it prevents you from having to
name every component of yours
dream you can have a single stream
definition with lots of nested
components and the natural extension is
you can basically scale up to basically
the natural size of a procedure just
like you would in a imperative language
and here's for example an FM radio where
we have a few inline components and the
interesting thing here is that there's a
pretty good correspondence between the
lines of the text and the actual
structure of the graph and that's
something that's hard to find in an
imperative language I mean if you want
to for example stitch nodes together
with edges is often very hard to
visualize the resulting structure of the
graph that you have but here if you just
go through the program you can see that
the a 2d component goes right over to
the a to da the demodulator to the
demodulator and so on and even for the
eye for the parallel components you can
kind of piece them together so that's
kind of how we think of building
programs any questions so far okay so
this is kind of how you'd go about
programming instrument but programming
is kind of a chugging plug activity
right nobody wants to be a code monkey
the reason we're all here is to see
what's beautiful about this programming
model right Don new said this I famous
computer scientist from Stanford during
huzzah turing award lecture you know
some programs are elegant some are
exquisite they are absolutely sparkling
my claim is that is possible to write
grand programs noble programs truly
magnificent ones right we want we want
the best programs possible it's not just
about making it work we want really
beautiful programs so what's beautiful
about the streaming domain what can you
go away with and say wow that was a
really beautiful expression of the
computation well for me I think one of
the interesting things here is the split
join construct split joins can really be
beautiful you know some mornings I just
wake up and I'm like ah I'm so glad I
live in a world with split dreams you
know and now you now split joins will be
part of your world you can say this
tomorrow this is just this is just
wonderful so okay what do we have in the
split join constructs you can duplicate
data you can do a round robin
communication pattern from one to
another or a round robin drawing now the
duplicate is pretty simple you just take
the input stream and duplicate it to all
the children no problem
what do you do for a round robin well
you pass n items from the input to a
given child so for example if n is 1
we'll just distribute one at a time to
the child's dreams and you get a pattern
like this a round robin just going
across and you can do the same thing on
the joiner side let's say you're joining
with a factor of 1 you're just reading
from the children and putting them into
a single stream okay so this is pretty
colorful but nothing too fancy yet let's
consider a different round robin factor
so round robin of two means that we peel
off two items from the input and pass
those items to the first output okay
there actually is going to be a quiz on
this so ask questions if this doesn't
make sense okay pass the next two items
and two items round robin like that and
you can actually have non-uniform
weights if you want to so on the right
let's say we're doing round robin 1 2 3
that means we pass one item from the
first stream 2 items from the next dream
and then three items from the third
stream okay pretty simple we're just
doing one two and three and so on does
this make sense I'm going to build on
this any questions okay so okay this was
colorful but this isn't totally
beautiful yet so what what's beautiful
about this well let's see how you might
write a matrix transpose okay something
you guys have probably all written at
one point in your life is transposing a
matrix let's say this matrix has m rows
and it has n columns going across and
we're starting with a representation in
which the stream is basically i think
this row major order yeah the first
thing that you're doing is going across
the rows before you're going to the next
the next row sorry you're going across
the columns and then down to the next
row so it's big zagging like this and
you want to pass through a transpose so
you zigzag the other way you do the
first column up and then the next column
and so on and this comes up a lot in a
stream program so it turns out you can
represent this as the split join oh
that's that's not good hmm just in my
moment of glory as well uh okay yeah
slides you can download slides actually
I can do this on the board this is the
thinking part anyways yeah
you just bring up Gmail I have a backup
on gmail hmm how can you focus on the
board so there's gonna be a little
exercise anyway okay ah here's what we
had we had em M rows and columns we
started with an interleaving like this
right and we want to go into a split
drawing and this will be a round robin
construct and what I want you to do is
fill in the round-robin weight and also
the number of streams and you can have a
round robin at the bottom and when it
comes out you want the opposite
interleaving mmm okay so there's three
three unknowns here what you're doing
the round robin bye you guys see that
over there hmm how many parallel streams
there are and what you're joining the
round robin by i guess i'm going to give
you a minute to think about this try try
to think about those safe to see if you
can figure out what these constants are
you just basically want to read from
this data in a row major pattern m rows
and n columns and end up with something
that's column major what are the values
for the constants so make sense ask the
question if it doesn't make sense yeah
based on the line you drew Grand Cross
that's like Street Street Street right
right right those those eyes are coming
down this dream you have a
one-dimensional stream is interleaved
like this so you'll be reading them like
this and then you output a
one-dimensional stream that is
threatening the columns so make sense
somebody asked another question yeah so
um in actual matrix transpose codes as
by addressing if nobody actually does it
sequentially like that because locality
issues instead is broken up into blocks
so there are ways to optimize this sort
of serialize it in you then can you then
capture the gym each of the node as a
block a set so you can hire actually do
that so know what happens is you do the
moon blocks and inside the blocks can do
it again we can do it at clever
and
any hypotheses someone is it and for the
first one we're smashing okay what do we
have and for the first one and producer
mm and same for the same mm yes okay I'm
time okay this is a hypothesis one other
hypotheses and M one and M 1 okay anyone
else
in the amendment one more 1111 okay
ladri is closing yep 1mm one mm okay any
last call okay I believe I believe two
of the ones submitted are correct wait
is this and yet okay I think this mmm
one works and one mmm works so let me
explain the 1n them this is how i like
to think about it one way to think about
this is we just want to move the whole
matrix you didn't okay this one yeah I
just want to move the whole matrix into
the split drawing so the way we can do
that is have n columns of the split
drawing since we have n columns of the
matrix and what we'll do is we'll just
do a round robin one at a time from the
columns of the matrix into the columns
of the split drawing so take the first
element send it to the left next element
next column so on so get the whole
matrix here now I want to read it out
column wise so we'll do a joiner of em
will read em from the left stream that
will read all mi tamanna column send it
out and then M items in the next column
and send it out that make sense how many
people understood that all right so if
you think about it you can also do it in
mm one that's basically uh yeah it's
very similar ah ok there we were and yes
we do 1 nm obviously read the matrix
down and then pull it down into columns
and it's very easy to write this as a
transpose so we just have a transpose
filter in which we're doing nothing no
computation and the actual rose or
actual contents of the split drawing and
we just split the data by one have n
different identity filters and then join
it back together by M
any questions about this and an
interesting way to write a transpose
okay so there's one more opportunity to
just shine here and that's a little more
interesting permutation called a bit
reversed ordering so this comes up in an
FFT and other algorithms the permutation
here is that we're taking the data at
the index N and let's say m has binary
digits b0 b1 up through BK and we want
to rearrange that data so this data goes
to a different index with the reversed
bits of its index so it'll if it was an
index n before it ends up at BK down to
b1 b0 so for example let's just look at
three digit binary numbers if we have 0
0 0 this is a one input item we're
reversing those digits you still get 0 0
0 item at index 1 will be 0 0 1 we want
to reorder that to index for ok 1000 10
stays the same 011 goes to 110 shifts
over and from there on at symmetric
sorry ok so here I'm writing the indices
so I'm not writing the data this is
index 0 1 2 3 up through index 8 or
index 70 cane on the bottom you have
indices 0 through 7 so the data will
actually be moved reordered like this
does that make sense it's a reordering
of data transformation makes sense other
questions ok so it turns out you can
write this as a split drawing and you
just need three different weights for
the round robins ok round robin with one
weight on the top here and two different
round robin weights on the bottom and
here i'm assuming you have three binary
digits in your index so you're
reordering in groups of eight ok so let
me give you a second to think about this
what are the values for these weights
I'll give you a hint in just a second or
ask another question yep
so what we're doing here is we're
exposing the communication pattern
that's the thing if you write this in an
imperative way you end up basically
having you're conflating basically the
data dependences with the reordering
pattern so what I'm trying to convey
here is how you can use the streaming
model to show how you're sending data
around because when you're on an
architecture like sell everything is
about the data motion you're taking data
from one place and you're trying to
efficiently get it to the producers are
the consumers and you really need the
compiler needs to understand the data
motion and also it's just another way of
writing it which I think it's actually
easier to understand once you see it's a
way to think about the actual reordering
for move from a theoretical standpoint
any wagers on this so what we want to do
if you think about the bit reverse
ordering what we want to do is
distribute the data by the low order
bits and then gather the data by the
high order bits so you want to fine
grain parody when you're shuffling you
could also do it the other way around
it's totally symmetrical but one way to
think about it is you want to find grain
parody when you're distributing data and
then coarse grained when you're coming
together anyone see it
give you ten more seconds
come on yeah it is a little bit tricky
okay well let me explain how it works so
one two and four okay so what what these
round-robin one splitters do is these
are basically the fine-grained paradiso
okay this first round robin that'll send
all the even bits to the left and all
the all the odd values to the right
right that's the the lowest order bit
because it's doing every other one
shuffling it left and right so this
round robin is seeing only the even
values now it's going to split them up
based on who's divisible by four now
we'll go to the left or go to the right
this is basically shuffling in in the
order of the bits from lower to bits to
high order bits so these will be ordered
by their in terms of their low order
bits and now we just want to read them
out from left to right just take the
order that we made with those round
robins and read them out from left to
right and since we have eight values you
can do that just by chunking them up
will read 22 and then we'll read these
two two and two and output all Layton
does that make sense okay so yes a
little bit clever except I think it's a
nice way of thinking about what a bit
reverse ordering memes and you can write
this in a very general way I just have a
recursive bit reverse filter for n
values in base case you only have two so
there's no reordering to do it when you
think about it so you're not doing any
computation otherwise you have a round
robin split in half and then have a
coarse grain joiner so you get a
structure like this if you're if you're
as you're building up just distributing
and then bringing back together in a
coarse-grained way okay ah let's see how
do I want to do this okay so one thing
to notice just one more example the
split drunk question okay good so in
general at the base of this hierarchy we
could have added some other filter to do
some computation identity just means
we're doing no computation it's a
predefined filter that just does nothing
I'm complex data it's sorry this is a
templated filter so we're reordering
complex values and we're passing the
input to the output
I'm here in general the language does
not have support for templates we only
do it for these base classes that's more
of an implementation detail Yeah right
now there isn't button nothing
fundamental there yeah I'll be right
yeah true so true path yes I two filters
I'm sorry here okay okay so we have to
add statements between the split and the
drawing so that branches to two parallel
streams is that your question yeah
there's not so the compiler will analyze
this a compile-time and it will pay and
we'll know these values of N and
propagate them down at compile time so
it'll basically on it'll basically
symbolically evaluate this code see
there are two branches and you can
unroll this communication pattern each a
statement separately adds another branch
in your children okay so you guys need a
box lone Hawks karen was another book so
this is about to get clear actually
other questions there's one where you
think about it yeah tell me wait say
again counting sort
wait sorry right um okay well is it
sorting that it's not really sorting
it's a permutation you could do a radix
sort this way so actually wait what I
want to show next is how you can morph
this program into a merge Thornton by
changing only a few lines so okay look
carefully don't blink ok there's Marge
story so very similar pattern this is
one of those idioms it's a recursive
idiom with split drawings but now in the
base case we have a sort so we basically
branch down well we ended up with was a
sort in the base case we're just sorting
a few values and we call merge sort
twice again and then we do emerge so
instead of identity at the base case
here we now have a basic sorting routine
and then we merge those results from
both sides and the only thing I change
in terms of the communication rates is
to be more efficient we just distributed
data in chunks instead of doing a
fine-grain splitting actually you can do
it however you want in amer start but
this is chunked up and let's just zoom
in here I this is how I merge sort looks
in stream it so we split the data I two
ways both directions come together do a
sort on both sides and then you merge
and so by having this you know you can
interleave pipelines and split joins
like this so you have these hierarchical
structures that are coming back together
just make sense ok I'm gonna hold off on
messaging actually um let me see what do
I want to cover ok let me actually skip
to the end oh I can show you this I'm
going to cut short a little bit so
here's how other programs look written
in stream it ok you can have a by tonic
sort so you see a lot of these regular
structures and the compiler can unroll
this and then map this to the substrate
this is how an FFT looks it's quite
elegant implementation of an FFT I be
good to go into in more detail you can
do things like block matrix multiply you
don't always have to have column or row
wise or during its natural to it to
split things up like this we have a lot
of DSP algorithms a filter Bank FM radio
with equalizer radar array front end
here's an mp3 decoder
and let's say I'm going to skip this
section just give you a taste for the
end here skipping one hundred slides
yeah okay so I just wanna give you feel
our biggest program written instrument
so far is the complete mpeg-2 encoder
and decoder so here's the mpeg-2 decoder
and I think you've seen block diagrams
of this already in the class and so it's
pretty natural expression you can really
get a feel for the high level structure
of the algorithm mapping down and for
example here in the top we're doing the
spatial decoding looking inside each
frame whereas at the bottom we're doing
the temporal decoding between two frames
the motion compensation and one thing
that I didn't have a chance to mention
is that we have a concept of teleport
messaging what this means is I showed
you how the steady state flow of data
goes between these actors in the stream
but sometimes you want to control the
stream as well for example this is the
variable length decoder at the top it's
parsing the input data it might want to
change how the processing is happening
downstream for example say that you have
you know in in this case you have
different picture types coming in and
you want to tell other components to
change the processing based on a
non-local effect now that's hard to do
if you just want static data rates but
what we have is this notion of a limited
dynamism where you're basically poking
into somebody else's dream and we let
you do that very precisely I didn't have
time to go into the details but you can
basically synchronize the arrival of
these messages with the data that's also
flowing through the stream and so in
this case we're sending through the
picture type and it really simplifies
the program code didn't have time for
details but why don't we put it in the
slides anyway if you're if you're
interested and if you do a similar
communication pattern in see it's a
little bit of a nightmare you have all
these different I basically memory
spaces different files and the control
information is basically going left and
right all over so this really helps both
the compiler in the programmer as well
and stream it so it's all implemented
it's about two thousand lines of code
and stream it which is about two thirds
of the size of the C code taking into
account similar functionality there it's
pretty big program you can write 48
static streams and then we expand that
more than 600 instantiated filters so
this gives you a lot of flexibility when
you're trying to get some parallelism
question oh the code you mean uh okay so
right now our current implementation we
duplicate a lot of code so it ends up
being bigger than it needs to be there's
no reason for us to do that that's kind
of a we have a research compiler that
makes that easy object wise we still
need to do that comparison yeah that's a
good question yeah another question okay
so let me cut to the end okay so we have
the stream at language we think it
really preserves the program structure
it's a new way of thinking about how you
orchestrate the data reordering with the
split drawings showing you who's
communicating to who and how you can
stitch together different pieces in your
program development and again really our
goal is to to get this scalable
multi-core performance but you can't get
people on board just on a performance
button you need to show them a new
programming model that actually makes
their lives easier so that's that's what
we're working on and thanks for
listening any last question yeah you
have a lot of computation stack that few
studies that were not sequential screams
thanks for example the output of your
that discrete cosine transform it's not
a stream of pixels you're going to have
you're going to have coefficients right
man which are in logical sorry Chum yeah
so you don't yes sure so depending on
the granularity of the computation you
don't need to pass individual values
over the stream for example you can have
a stream that inputs a whole array at a
time and so we basically advocated if
you if you have something that
coarse-grained you should be passing an
array or a macroblock in the case of
MPEG or instead of coefficients in a
structure so when you have coarse
grained parallelism you write your
program in a coarse-grained way that the
fine grain things I showed for the bit
interleaving and so on is more for the
fine grain programs instead
can you stream over an array right so in
a stream of streams so to speak right so
there's an interesting multi-dimensional
problem there right now we've taken a
one dimensional approach so so far
basically the programmer has to set an
iteration order and end up with a
one-dimensional stream coming into and
out of every filter we're working on
extending that yeah when you have
basically streams of two dimensional
data you'd like the freedom to either
iterate basically in time or in space
depending on what you're doing and so I
think that's more of a research problem
so far we've just been doing a one
dimensional representation yeah it's
good point yeah why don't you try to be
synchronous dataflow line yes it's
supposed to be repaired yep so our
philosophy has been that you want to
start with the with the most kind of
basic block of a stream program and
optimize it really well and then you can
stitch those together into higher-level
blocks so we think of synchronous
dataflow is being kind of the basic
block of streaming you know what's
coming in you know what's coming out and
even if you have a more general model
there'll be pieces that fit under there
synchronous dataflow model and so we saw
a lot of optimization opportunities in
there and really knowing those io rays
can let you do a lot of things that you
can't do in a general model so wanted to
get the simple case right first and
actually kind of our focus now is that
it is on expanding and how do you look
at the heterogeneous systems and how do
you optimize more dynamic systems yep
okay yes you can check out our web page
yeah if you google for stream it I'm
sure you can find it yeah we have a
public release I yet send us any
problems we want to actually it's a good
test we want to make sure it it works
for everyone so but I mean we've had you
know hundreds of downloads there a lot
of people using stream it so it
shouldn't break if you if you download
it yet okay good thanks